y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia de kobe 19 en nuestro
continente a continuación les presento
algunos de los temas que vamos a tener
en esta visión en nuestra habitual
consulta con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez epidemiólogo y asesor científico
de france 24 hablaremos sobre la nueva
versión de omicron se trata de una sub
variante llamada punto 2 y que podría no
percibirse en las pruebas psr también
hablaremos sobre la píldora que facer
desarrolló contra el coronavirus llamada
pax lobby que eeuu ya aprobó para su uso
también en este programa daremos un
panorama general de cómo avanza la
pandemia en argentina veremos como el
uso de la vacuna rusa sputnik ve en
suelo argentino le puede servir a moscú
para mostrar como evidencia ante la umh
para buscar la aprobación también iremos
a guatemala para dar una mirada de la
situación en ese país y como se ve
afectada la industria del turismo debido
a las restricciones que cuesta unidos al
incluir a esta nación centroamericana en
un listado de alto riesgo precisamente
por la situación epidemiológica también
hablaremos de las nuevas pruebas que se
están haciendo en cuba con una posible
vacuna contra el kobe 19 llamada mambisa
lo particular es que ésta es de uso
nasal actualmente el centro de
ingeniería genética y
biotecnología de ensayos con 120
voluntarios
comenzamos el programa y entonces lo
hacemos con cifras vamos a ver cómo está
el panorama de cómo está avanzando la
pandemia de kobe 19 en nuestro
continente comenzamos en el salvador en
centroamérica en donde hay poco más de
127 mil casos activos o contraídos del
virus desde el inicio de la pandemia de
ellos casi tres mil 900 personas ya han
fallecido debido al joven 19 en este
país vamos a colombia allí ya suman 58
millones de diagnósticos positivos y más
de 133 mil personas han fallecido de
kobe 19 en ese país mientras que en
paraguay los casos rondan los 560 mil y
alrededor de 17.000 personas ya
fallecieron desde que comenzó la crisis
sanitaria debido a la pandemia de kobe
en cuba ya comenzaron las pruebas en
humanos de la que podría ser una nueva
vacuna contra el kobe 19 mambisa es una
fórmula intranasal sería la primera en
su tipo está en fase de ensayo y llega
cuando este país caribeño ya ha visto
también un incremento en el contagio con
más de tres mil casos diarios en la
última semana aquí les contamos de qué
se trata
la fórmula intranasal cubana mambisas se
convierte en la primera de 11 en su tipo
en comenzar la fase de estudios clínicos
en humanos en el mundo
el método diseñado por el centro de
ingeniería genética y biotecnología de
cuba ya se aplica convalecientes del
cobi 19 y como dosis de refuerzo en el
país caribeño
[Música]
mientras
en la vulnerable
además de mambisa cuba ha desarrollado
tres vacunas contra el cob y 19 la bda
la la soberana 2 y soberana plus que
según estudios no verificados por
expertos externos tienen una eficacia de
más del 90 por ciento las autoridades
sanitarias afirman que cerca del 88 por
ciento de la población total de cuba que
cuenta con más de 11,2 millones de
habitantes ya fue inoculada con las 3
dosis de estas vacunas es decir con el
esquema completo la jefa del
departamento de comunicación del
ministerio de salud considera que han
podido controlar la variante omicron de
rápida propagación
las vacunas cubanas mostraron
efectividad en el control del pico
pandémico delta y en la actualidad la
campaña de dosis de refuerzo ha logrado
que el pico pandémico omicron haya
tenido una intensidad menor que en otros
países sin embargo esas fórmulas aún no
han sido reconocidas por la organización
mundial de la salud aunque han recibido
la autorización de uso de emergencia se
aplique en países como venezuela
nicaragua irán vietnam y se está
negociando su envío con 15 naciones más
de bajos ingresos
los invito para que demos una mirada
general a argentina país en donde hay
debate en torno al regreso a las clases
presenciales y en donde la experiencia
en este país con el uso de la vacuna
sputnik be podría servir de evidencia de
su efectividad ante la ms desde allí
desde argentina nos conectamos con
natalio coso y nuestro corresponsal hola
natalio bueno comienzo entonces
preguntándole por el panorama general de
cómo está la situación en argentina el
avance de la variante o micro en
vacunación y personas contagiadas y
fallecidas
enero en mes de vacaciones en argentina
y todos tenían mucha expectativa de
poder disfrutar después de tantos meses
y meses de pandemia pero yo como en todo
el mundo de la variante omicron y esos
planes muchas veces se fueron por tierra
muchísima muchísima gente empezó a
contagiarse es muy difícil no conocer a
alguna persona que esté en este momento
con kobe ya ha pasado coin es un pico
muy alto los casos crecieron muy
rápidamente muchos días de 100.000 o más
casos con una altísima positividad sobre
los testeos empezó a haber una especie
de estabilización o una bajada incluso
en el número de casos también han
crecido ahora después de tantas semanas
de alto número de casos el número de
muertes de todos modos el número de
fallecidos sigue sin alcanzar lo que
había alcanzado en la anterior ola lo
cierto es que las autoridades los
especialistas dan cuenta de que la
vacunación
teniendo efecto en argentina pero el
número de casos es muy alto todavía
todos los días y se está esperando que
finalmente empiece a ceder hay
expectativas de que las próximas semanas
posiblemente empiece a ceder esta ola de
kobe 19 sobre todo teniendo en cuenta
que hacia fines de febrero a veces un
poco antes dependiendo de las provincias
comenzarán las clases y el porcentaje de
niños de 13 a 17 años con esquema
completo de vacunación es bastante más
bajo que en el de la población general
que está en torno al 75 por ciento y en
el caso de los menores de 3 a 17 años
está en torno al 60 por ciento así que
las autoridades están haciendo un
esfuerzo muy grande para convencer
a los adultos que lleven a los niños y a
los adolescentes a vacunarse a completar
esquemas de vacunación
natalio también hay varias novedades en
torno a las restricciones que siguen
vigentes allí en argentina pero hay
sobre todo cambios en las restricciones
para ingresar al país de qué estamos
hablando y qué restricciones se
mantienen allí en este país suramericano
pero hay una combinación de medidas por
un lado exigir y por un lado relajar la
exigencia viene por el lado de lo que
muchos llaman pase sanitario que es
solicitar para ciertas actividades la
presentación de un esquema de vacunación
completo esto es bastante fuerte en la
provincia de buenos aires donde se suele
solicitar por ejemplo en restaurants o
en espacios de convocatoria pública por
ejemplo para espectáculos pero también
para viajes de media y larga distancia
dentro de la provincia de buenos aires e
incluso hay algunas
universidades que están empezando a
pedir el esquema completo de vacunación
o un justificativo de por qué no está
completo pero también hay relajamiento
se están acortando muchas veces los
tiempos en que por ejemplo los contactos
estrechos tienen que estar aislados
especialmente por supuesto si no tienen
síntomas y son personas con vacunación
completa y sobre todo con una tercer
dosis de refuerzo también se está
relajando por ejemplo la exigencia de la
entrada al país con testeo para aquellos
argentinos y residentes que ya tengan el
esquema compre la vacunación ellos no
van a necesitar a partir de fines de
enero a realizarse un testeo para que
hoy 19 entonces esto va de la mano
mayores relajamiento de algunas medidas
para aquellos que tienen vacunación
completa y algunas dificultades más
grandes para aquellos que no han
completado sus esquemas de vacunación
natalio también destacado esta semana
esas afirmaciones y esas declaraciones
por parte de la ministra de salud de
argentina carla vizzotti que dijo que
van a seguir estrechando lazos con rusia
porque la experiencia argentina con la
vacuna sputnik be puede servirle a moscú
como una evidencia de efectividad ante
organismos internacionales como la ms o
autoridades de otros países que más han
dicho en torno a este tema
esta semana la ministra de salud
argentina carla vizzotti estuvo
visitando la federación rusa estuvo en
moscú estuvo hablando con sus padres
allí respecto a estrategias comunes
entre ambos países de cara a lo que
sigue de la pandemia de kobe 19 cómo se
puede trabajar en conjunto recordemos
algo muy importante
argentina fue el tercer país después de
rusia y bielorrusia en aprobar la vacuna
rusa es public be y comenzó a aplicarla
a fines de 2020 fue clave en su
estrategia de inoculación en el contexto
de la pandemia de kobe 19 esta vacuna y
argentina ha trabajado siempre en forma
muy estrecha con rusia de hecho se había
empezado en un momento la fabricación de
la vacuna aquí en el país y argentina
carla vizzotti dijo que también el país
se propone presentar a la organización
mundial de la salud la evidencia que
existe en argentina de eficacia de
seguridad de la vacuna de cara a la
aprobación de sputnik vez por parte de
la organización mundial de la salud
no la ha probado todo esto ocurre apenas
días antes de que el presidente alberto
fernández viaje a rusia donde se reunirá
con su par en ese país con vladimir
putin natalio muchas gracias por este
reporte desde argentina natalia con soy
nuestro corresponsal en ese país
suramericano dándonos un panorama de lo
que está sucediendo allí en torno a la
pandemia veamos entonces ahora cómo ha
avanzado la vacunación en el continente
americano les presentamos a continuación
el porcentaje de la población que ya
tiene el esquema de vacunación completo
veamos a ver cómo están las cifras
comenzamos en el caribe república
dominicana casi con el 53 por ciento de
los habitantes ya tiene todas las dosis
recordemos que las dosis variedad
dependiendo de la vacuna que haya
recibido la persona en colombia la
estadística es un poco más alta ya
superan el 60 por ciento en cambio en
chile que es uno de los pioneros de la
vacunación en nuestro continente ya la
cifra supera el 88 por ciento de la
población con el esquema de vacunación
completo recordemos que este país es el
único de américa y el segundo en el
mundo que comenzó a aplicar una cuarta
dosis como refuerzo ante la aparición de
la variante omicron en el mundo
en la última semana américa registró más
de 8 millones de contagios o por kobe 19
así lo reportó la organización
panamericana de la salud la ope s esto
representa un aumento del 32% respecto a
la semana anterior aún así algunos
países están relajando las medidas
preventivas como está ocurriendo por
ejemplo en perú en ecuador y en
nicaragua
latinoamérica la región con la tasa de
vacunación más alta del mundo se estaría
acercando a una nueva normalidad pero le
dice adiós al toque de queda tras más de
22 meses en vigencia además recibió el
pasado viernes el primer lote de vacunas
pediátricas contra el cob y 19 para
inmunizar a partir del lunes a más de 4
millones de niños entre los 5 y 11 años
de edad esta es una muestra demostrando
de que los niños si tienen derecho
y no solamente tienen derecho a la
educación sino tienen derecho a estar
sanos hoy tenemos un desafío para abrir
las escuelas
nos encargaremos como gobierno de las
escuelas estoy en mejores condiciones
sobre la estructura su techo su
alimentación pero el mayor reto
es tener niños sanos según el ministerio
de salud de este país más de 3 millones
de personas han contraído el virus y más
de 200.000 muertos a causa de esto la
tasa de mortalidad más alta a nivel
global por esta enfermedad ecuador por
su parte contempla el retorno presencial
voluntario y progresivo de los alumnos a
los centros educativos en todos los
niveles se respetará el área de 225
metros cuadrados por persona en el día
mundial de la educación ratificamos que
asistir a la escuela no se puede
considerar un riesgo innecesario es un
servicio público y un derecho humano que
debemos garantizar desde el 7 de junio
avanzamos en un retorno progresivo
voluntario y con medidas de bioseguridad
en los últimos días en los niveles de
contagio han disminuido en este país la
segunda semana de este mes hubo un pico
máximo de más de 47 mil casos mientras
que en la tercera se reportaron poco más
de 37 mil infecciones entre tanto más de
18 millones de nicaragüenses regresaron
a las aulas escolares bajo el contexto
de la pandemia de kobe 19 por tercer año
consecutivo
según el gobierno de nicaragua el 53 por
ciento de la población mayor de 2 años
ya cuenta con el esquema completo de
vacunación aunque la organización
panamericana de la salud estima que el
porcentaje ronda el 45 por ciento
seguimos con nuestra ronda por
diferentes países del continente
americano vamos a hablar ahora de
guatemala allí está avanzando muy
lentamente la vacunación a la vez que
intentan reactivar la economía entre
ellas su industria más lucrativa el
turismo que se ha visto también afectado
por las restricciones impuestas por eeuu
que recomendó no viajar a este país
centroamericano precisamente por la
situación epidemiológica que está
presentando vamos a conocer los detalles
de la situación allí saludamos a andrés
suárez jaramillo corresponsal de france
24 que nos informa desde antigua
guatemala y está debutando con nosotros
hoy en el programa con este primer
reporte andrés un gusto saludarlo y cuál
es el panorama general entonces en este
país centroamericano en torno a los
casos el regreso a las actividades
vacunados y fallecidos
hola santiago que tal fijense que
guatemala es otro de los países
latinoamericanos donde ha crecido
exponencialmente el número de casos de
contagio por coronavirus de diciembre a
enero en gran parte por las
aglomeraciones en las fiestas
decembrinas pero también por el avance
de la nueva variante omicron esto se
puede ver de la siguiente forma mientras
en diciembre guatemala contabilizó
aproximadamente o poco más de 10 mil
contagios de coronavirus en lo corrido
de enero esa cifra se ha multiplicado
por 5 y ya se cuentan alrededor de 50
mil casos de contagio así las cosas el
panorama de kobe 19 en guatemala es de
680 mil casos de contagio desde el
inicio de la pandemia esto representa el
4 por ciento de la población teniendo en
cuenta que es un país de 18 millones de
habitantes y de esos 600 casi 680.000
casos de contagio alrededor o poco más
de 16.000 personas han fallecido por lo
cual el ministerio de salud guatemalteco
alerta roja en varias de las
municipalidades del país
andrés viendo un poco la situación de
guatemala y las cifras vemos que están
un poco atrasados en cuanto a la
vacunación si se compara con algunos
países vecinos como el salvador costa
rica y panamá que son los líderes en
centroamérica en cuanto a la vacunación
con nicaragua no hay unas cifras muy
claras y honduras se está haciendo lo
propio y ha avanzado un poco gracias a
donaciones que ha recibido el salvador
cómo está entonces la vacunación allí en
guatemala en líneas generales
santiago en materia de vacunación a
guatemala han ingresado más de 23
millones de dosis de vacunas contra el
cob y 19 de las cuales el gobierno ya ha
logrado administrar poco más de 13
millones de las mismas actualmente el
foco de la vacunación está puesto en los
grupos de adolescentes en los grupos de
niños y se critica que no se haya
comenzado la vacunación para el grupo
poblacional de los 5 a los 11 años con
respecto a los países centroamericanos
que ya avanzan en este mecanismo en este
plan de vacunación a pocas horas de
guatemala en el salvador el gobierno de
najib bukele comenzó a administrar estas
vacunas para los niños de 5 a 11 años
desde el pasado septiembre desde el
septiembre de 2021 y países como
honduras y costa rica ya recibieron los
lotes necesarios de vacunas pzifer la
que recomienda la organización mundial
de la salud en el mes de enero en cambio
el gobierno llama 'the y parece estar en
mora ni siquiera ha firmado un convenio
de administración de estas dosis por lo
cual la procuraduría de los derechos
humanos instauró una orden de amparo
ante la corte constitucional en contra
del presidente alejandro giammatei y del
ministro de salud andrés recientemente
eeuu se emitió una advertencia de viaje
para sus ciudadanos para que eviten ir a
guatemala precisamente por la situación
epidemiológica que se está presentando
allí esto claramente
dificulta la reactivación económica
porque si algo le estaba apostando a
guatemala era reactivar la industria
turística que es fundamental para el
desarrollo de las regiones y para la
economía del país esto entonces
entorpece la llegada de turistas cómo se
está viviendo allí la situación
santiago la nueva variante omicron ha
sido confirmada por el laboratorio
nacional de la salud como la variante
predominante en los contagios de covite
19 en enero y en lo corrido del 2022
aquí en el país centroamericano esto ha
hecho que el gobierno de los eeuu a
través de la embajada estadounidense en
guatemala haya ascendido de nivel 2 a
nivel 3 la advertencia para los viajeros
pidiéndoles que reconsideren venir al
país centroamericano y es que recordemos
que del total de los viajeros que
ingresan internacionalmente para el
turismo en guatemala el 40 por ciento de
ellos son estadounidenses y es evidente
a la vista en ciudades como esta antigua
o en otros lugares icónicos como atitlán
o las ruinas mayas de tikal de manera
que para el instituto guatemalteco de
turismo se espera que en lo corrido del
2022 y a medida que vayan disminuyendo
el número de casos de contagio se
relajen las medidas y sobre todo que el
gobierno estadounidense relaje las
medidas de viajes para un país tan
apetecidos por los estadounidenses antes
muchas gracias por este completo reporte
desde guatemala era andrés suárez
jaramillo y en la cámara aurora valls
reportando nos desde la ciudad de
antigua en guatemala hoy debutando en
nuestro programa primera vez que tenemos
cubrimiento desde este país
centroamericano vamos a dejar
centroamérica y nos vamos ahora hasta
eeuu al menos unas 20.000 personas
protestaron en la ciudad de washington
en contra del uso de las mascarillas y
la exigencia de un pase de vacunación la
mayoría de los manifestantes tenían
pancartas también en respaldo al
expresidente donald trump quien
reiteradamente cuestionó la eficacia de
estas medidas sanitarias para combatir
la pandemia de kobe 19 veamos
con banderas y pancartas miles de
personas de todas partes de eeuu se
manifestaron en contra del uso de las
mascarillas y el pase de vacuna
obligatorio la marcha de fernández
empezó en la base del washington
monument y llegó hasta el lincoln
memorial
estoy marchando porque estoy
completamente en contra de los mandatos
creo que no son éticos creo que son
ineficaces y creo que son
anticonstitucionales
viva en los eeuu de américa este es un
país libre deberíamos ser libres de
decir lo que queremos y lo que no
queremos especialmente en nuestros
cuerpos
el otoño pasado el presidente de eeuu
emitió una orden que exigía que unos 35
millones de trabajadores del gobierno se
vacunarán antes del 22 de noviembre
salvo una excepción religiosa o médica
de lo contrario enfrentarían disciplina
o despido pero los jueces bloquearon la
medida el 13 de enero la corte suprema
de este país anuló el mandato de
vacunación o prueba de kobe para los
empleados de empresas que tengan más de
100 empleados más no para el personal de
los centros de salud donde unos 17
millones de personas
en la libertad médica ha sido
secuestrada por los hospitales las
compañías de seguro el gobierno y las
grandes farmacéuticas médicos ahora es
el momento de ponerse de pie y salvar
nuestra profesión
según un estudio realizado por la
organización our world in that a más de
209 millones de personas se han
inoculado con el esquema completo en
eeuu es decir el 63 6% de la población
total que cuenta con más de 329 millones
de habitantes y saludo a esta hora el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo y asesor científico de
france 24 ya está con nosotros para
nuestra habitual consulta doctor pérez
como siempre un gusto saludarlo en esta
oportunidad en conexión telefónica con
nosotros comienzo preguntándole el
doctor por los anuncios hechos esta
semana por las autoridades de eeuu que
dieron el aval para que la píldora pax
lo bit que es un fármaco desarrollado
por facer pueda entrar en circulación ya
de manera comercial
pastilla cumple con la misión que tiene
una vacuna o es más como un medicamento
preventivo y en qué casos debe ser usado
en personas que tienen tipos de kobe
graves o personas que están
hospitalizadas o las personas lo pueden
tomar en su confinamiento en sus
viviendas
santiago esta es una aproximación muy
interesante porque no es práctico sino
un tratamiento éste es un tratamiento
farmacológico son tabletas que se toman
en personas que tienen píxeles leves a
moderadas es decir que no hacen en los
ambientes hospitalarios sino para los
pacientes que se pueden manejar en casa
lo que se ha visto con este tratamiento
es que una vez se administre
tempranamente una se inician los
intentos se reducen más de un 70 por
ciento la probabilidad de tener
complicaciones como hospitalización o
requerimientos de oxígeno entonces hace
parte de hacer parte de este de estas
herramientas que necesitamos para
bloquear el virus y poder tratar a los
pacientes tempranamente
doctor importante esta aclaración que
usted hace pasó a preguntarle ahora por
la bea punto 2 que es la nueva versión
de la variante omicron que es en este
momento la variante de más circulación
en el mundo porque es de alto contagio
porque se le dice variante silenciosa y
qué diferencia tiene con la variante
omicron original
entre los virus hay una producción de
linajes que son diferentes entre unos
entre ellos por unas variaciones
antigénicas y estas variantes mínimas
variantes silenciosas aun cuando los
cambios son mínimos en su estructura
antigénica es decir la que genera el
pensó que es lo que se ve es que estas
mutaciones que se acumulan tienen por
ejemplo en este caso mayor capacidad de
transmisibilidad pero no es un cambio
dramático en los virus ni es que nos
vamos a enfrentar a una nueva variante
viral sino son pequeños cambios que
hacen los virus en ese proceso de
dinámica viral que es de alta
replicación por ahora no hay nada
alarmante que nos venga con estas sus
variantes km pero doctor el hecho de que
se estén dando a conocer estas versiones
de la variante o micro no quiere decir
que el virus está teniendo como una
mayor rapidez para desarrollar
diferentes digamos estrategias en su
composición para poder esquivar digamos
las vacunas que ya hemos recibido
en diferentes partes del mundo esto no
quiere decir que el virus es un poco más
inteligente y está mutando moviéndose
más rápido para poder así sortear las
vacunas
no no los virus mutan constantemente y
mientras hayan personas no a unas
personas infectadas van a ver variantes
en sus variantes en gran cantidad por
eso la necesidad de la inmunización en
todos nosotros no escribimos aprendas
simplemente es un proceso de adaptación
no no lo hace más rápido ni más temprano
es la dinámica que tienen este y muchos
otros vídeos para adaptarse y para ser
más efectivas y eficaces
infección llamémosla así pero el
santiago es importante recordar que
todos los virus mutan y este es uno de
esos vídeos que va a notar entre más
personas infectadas haya más riesgo al
que hayan en su educación es por eso
todos debemos vacunar o alquilar si
tenemos un doctor quiero invitarlo para
que oigamos y escuchemos estas
declaraciones del director de la oms
pedrosa among everest jesús que habló
sobre un escenario posible a raíz de lo
que está sucediendo en europa en donde
hay un alto contagio de la variante
omicron y él que puede ser el inicio de
el fin de la pandemia de kobe 19 para
este año escuchados live in trees news
all of the strategies and tools
comprensivo way we can see los países
usan todas estas estrategias y
herramientas de manera integral podemos
terminar con la fase aguda de la
pandemia este año podemos lograr que el
kobe 19 deje de ser una emergencia de
salud global y podemos hacerlo este año
qué significa eso significa que debemos
lograr nuestro objetivo de vacunar al
70% de la población de cada país con un
enfoque en los grupos de mayor riesgo de
population of every can't read with the
fockers on the most a trees groups
doctor pérez quiero conocer su opinión
sobre estas declaraciones un plan muy
ambicioso tal vez un poco precipitado
por parte de la ms
yo creo que la directriz es clara en que
tenemos que vacunar más de 70% no un
país no una región sino el planeta que
vio que él creía llamar los segundos ya
sabemos que cuando las personas están
vacunas y se infectan por colin tiene
una inmunidad mucho más prolongada como
este contraste ha sido tan masivo con la
variante omiten pero tenemos gran
cantidad de personas vacunadas es
probable que en el segundo en este este
año hayan inmunidad que nos proteja y
que nos permita evitar esta propagación
tan masiva y de vacunarlos
frecuentemente para controlarlo y volver
esta pandemia venden yo creo que sí es
un mensaje claro esperanzador pero
aparte de una premisa se debe vacunar no
una región no un país sino todos debemos
vacunarles vacunarnos y con esta digamos
masiva infección por coli pues vamos a
tener la posibilidad de salir de esto
más pronto el ok que lo que creemos
esperemos que así sea doctor muchas
gracias doctor pérez por estar con
nosotros acompañarnos en el programa y
hacer esta explicación y aclaraciones
para la audiencia de france 24 muchas
gracias bueno brevemente les presentamos
otras noticias destacadas de la semana
en nuestro continente les cuento
rápidamente que la autoridad sanitaria
de medicamentos de colombia el invima
recomendó aprobar el uso de la píldora
mono pira beer desarrollada por la
farmacéutica merck sólo podrá usarse en
adultos no vacunados con algún factor de
riesgo y que tengan síntomas leves o
moderados pasamos ahora a puerto rico-
ahora todos los funcionarios del
gobierno central e incluso los
contratistas deberán tener las dosis de
refuerzo hasta el 28 de febrero tendrán
plazo para completar su esquema de
vacunación y vamos a finalizar en el sur
del continente en uruguay allí los
estudiantes y docentes que hayan tenido
algún contacto de riesgo y no presenten
síntomas ya no tendrán que quedarse en
su casa aislados podrán continuar con
las clases presenciales que serán
retomadas a partir del mes de marzo una
vez termine el ciclo de vacaciones de
verano hay en este país suramericano
no muy lejos de allí en brasil están
registrando los niveles más altos de
contagios por kobe 19 desde el inicio de
la emergencia sanitaria en la última
semana el país superó en múltiples
ocasiones los 200.000 casos en solamente
un día la cifra más alta reportada hasta
ahora la situación sanitaria es tan
crítica que la fundación fiocruz
advirtió que el 19 de los 27 estados
están en alerta porque superan ya el 60
por ciento de la capacidad hospitalaria
en siete de ellos más del 80 por ciento
de las camas de unidades de cuidados
intensivos ya están ocupadas la
situación es todavía más crítica en el
distrito federal en brasilia en donde la
hospitalización está completamente al
límite
y también los contagios en chile
aumentaron en un 75% en la última semana
la principal causa según las autoridades
es la variante omicron que es más
contagiosa ya les hemos contado sobre
ella los centros de atención reportan
que los pacientes más graves son
aquellos que no se habían vacunado
o micrón llega hasta el denominado fin
del mundo es decir hasta la austral
región chilena de magallanes a pesar de
ser uno de los lugares más remotos del
planeta con una densidad poblacional muy
baja esta región registra una tasa de
positividad por encima del 18 por ciento
una de las más altas del país que está
registrando más de 20.000 casos diarios
más del doble de lo que pronosticaba el
gobierno aunque la presión hospitalaria
sigue siendo baja algunos laboratorios
están colapsando dadas las cientos de
personas que llegan para realizarse una
prueba pcr en las últimas semanas ha
aumentado más del 50% del número de
ingreso de muestras a nuestro
laboratorio siempre hemos dicho que
nuestro laboratorio tenía una capacidad
de hasta 1200 muestras para procesar
llegando incluso algunos días a procesar
1.700 muestras sin embargo el gobierno
no contempla nuevos confinamientos más
bien apunta a reducir los aforos en las
regiones más afectadas ya fomentar la
vacunación que de acuerdo a
investigaciones científicas reduce el
riesgo de
la mayoría de los pacientes que han
ingresado básicamente tienen una o dos
de las vacunas que están estipuladas por
el ministerio
impuesta hasta hasta la fecha y los más
graves que han ingresado son pacientes
que no están vacunados según un estudio
realizado por la organización hour world
in that a más del 92% de la población
total de chile que cuenta con más de 19
millones de habitantes se ha inoculado
con el esquema completo la tasa de
vacunación más alta de latinoamérica más
de 12 millones de personas han recibido
la dosis de refuerzo y las personas
inmunodeprimidas ya pueden aplicarse una
cuarta dosis en febrero los mayores de
55 años también podrán hacerlo
ahora demos un vistazo a otras noticias
relacionadas con el hobby 19 que fueron
destacadas en las redes sociales el
diario el financiero pública méxico dice
no otra vez a la vacunación de menores
de edad sin con movilidad es la
controversia en ese país vuelve a estar
sobre la mesa pero la secretaria de
salud de méxico indicó que el plan
nacional de vacunación mexicano sigue
todas las pautas de la o ms que dan
prioridad a cuatro grupos de prioridad
entre los que no están precisamente los
menores de edad
los cdc de estados unidos agregaron ocho
destinos de américa latina y el caribe a
esa lista de lugares de riesgo por kobe
19 comentábamos el caso de guatemala
esta agencia gubernamental afirmó que
dichos lugares o regiones representan un
riesgo muy alto de contagio entre ellas
hay varios puntos específicos o regiones
puntuales en colombia en costa rica
también en perú la república dominicana
la isla francesa de guadalupe la isla
francesa de san bartolomé y san martín
el diario 'el comercio' pública ecuador
ofrece apoyar la distribución regional
de vacunas contra el kobe 19 esta
propuesta surgió tras la participación
del presidente ecuatoriano guillermo
lazo en el foro para el progreso de
américa del sur
allí laso indicó que la meta es que
ecuador produzca fármacos contra el kobe
19 y también otras patologías en los
próximos 18 meses
es todo por hoy en nuestro resumen de
kobe 19 la semana en américa recuerden
sigan cuidando de coronavirus la
pandemia sigue vigente en nombre del
equipo de producción y de mis compañeros
en el máster les agradecemos habernos
acompañado hoy y por supuesto los
invitamos a seguir en sintonía de
france24 siga con nosotros nos vemos la
próxima semana
[Música]